Okay.
Thank you for coming bright and early.
Uh, 9:00 a.m. at the start of the
conference
uh for LLMs for web devs. Uh, GPT in 600
lines of vanilla JavaScript. Um, I think
you guys are going to have a great
conference. I was here last year. I
thoroughly enjoyed it. Um, and I think
this is a great way to kick things off.
If you're just coming to this field or
this conference without any background
in machine learning, this is your
missing AI degree that'll help make the
rest of the conference I think hopefully
a lot more valuable.
So, if you're just joining us and came
in, you can go to
spreadsheetsarealluneed.ai
um, and there's a Discord link in the
upper menu. Uh, click on that and then
go to the AI Engineer World's Fair 2025
room and then there's a link to download
the GPT-2 model weights in the pinned
message at the top. Takes a little while
to download that, so I would download
that and get started.
Uh, if cuz the Wi-Fi might be a little
bit slow.
We're going to be using that in a bit.
Okay, we're going to do something
special today.
Uh, it is a talk and I will be doing a
lot of talking at you and we'll be
running code, so it is a workshop. But
our mission today is to break Clark's
third law.
You might be familiar with the science
fiction author Arthur C. Clarke and his
famous maxim that any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic.
And nowhere is that, you know, more true
or relevant today than when it comes to
large language models. These are
seemingly magical machines that can
produce life-like text, automate tasks
as agents, and maybe even replace humans
in certain contexts.
And if you ask somebody
how these work or you go online, you're
liable to get the impression that you
need to have semesters of linear algebra
and calculus before you can begin taking
your first machine learning class and
understand how these work.
And yes, that's true if you want to be a
machine learning engineer.
But if you just want to understand how
these work and you're a builder on top
of them,
I'm here to tell you that is not true.
Do not believe them.
You don't need all that sophistication
if you just want to have a really
accurate model of how a transformer
works.
I know
because I was here last year. I gave a
talk called spreadsheetsarealluneed
where I showed an Excel worksheet that
implemented all of GPT-2 small entirely
in pure Excel functions.
And then I took that spreadsheet and I
turned it into a class that I taught
online
where I took people tab by tab through
how the entire model works.
And not everyone was even an engineer.
So, one of my favorites is this guy.
This Joe here is a CFO. He's just
naturally good at at Excel. And that
gave him everything he needed combined
with the sheet to understand how a large
language model works on the inside. And
he says, "This is great.
I had no experience with machine
learning or AI concepts before." Yet he
was able to walk away with a very good
understanding of how they work.
So, what I'm going to do today is
compress that class, which is about 8
hours, down to these 2 hours today and
explain how the transformer works. And I
show up today or this year at the
conference with this. Instead of Excel,
because not every one of us have a job
that require us to be really good at
Excel, uh, we're using a vanilla
JavaScript implementation because a lot
of folks who come to AI engineering as a
field have a web development or full
stack JavaScript background. And so, if
that's your background, you are perfect
the way you are. You don't need to learn
Python if you just want to understand
how a model works and you're still going
to use TypeScript and Next.js around the
model, but you still want to have a good
understanding of how it works.
So, today's approach is I'm going to
give you the background to understand
the code and we're going to take a a
brief walk through of it.
I'm going to focus more on the why than
on the what. So, we'll take a look at
the code, but I'm going to spend a lot
of time building intuition and
background to understand the code.
And then, instead of complex equations,
I'm going to use analogies and examples
to make it more tangible.
Okay, and the background you need to
have is first of all just motivation.
Uh, and a curiosity to understand how
these work on the inside.
Uh, any science, technology, engineering
background is sufficient. Prior
programming experience, especially in
JavaScript, uh, but you don't need to
know React or Vue. We're going to just
use vanilla JavaScript. And then some
awareness, I would call it, of linear
algebra, meaning you just need to know
what a matrix multiplication is.
Uh, you don't need to be a hotshot
JavaScript ninja. You don't need prior
AI or ML background. And you don't need,
you know, deep calculus or linear
algebra fluency.
Okay, and the key resources for today
are going to be our JavaScript
implementation of GPT-2.
what you're want to do is select all of
those files and drag it into this
section here. You can once
uh, when it uh, when it's done loading
all those files, it'll look like this.
It'll say ready, all model parameters
loaded. When it's not loaded, it'll be
in red and it'll say, you know, please
add the files.
And what it's doing is it's actually
loading all those GPT-2 parameters
locally into your index.db database. And
you can see here, it's basically about
1.5 GB. Now, Chrome will let you do that
uh, if you've got sufficient disk space
on your hard drive.
But the benefit of doing this is now the
entire model is running locally
in vanilla JavaScript on your browser.
In fact, to run and debug this, you
don't need anything else. You could pull
the internet connection and it should
still work.
And the way this is set up is similar to
a Python notebook if you've encountered
one of those. We have these cells uh,
and every cell has a play button which
will run what's inside it. And there are
two types of cells. One type of cell is
just JavaScript code and you can open
these and expand these if you want. It's
just vanilla JavaScript code. Our
matrices, for example, are just simple
2D JavaScript arrays.
And if I hit play, it'll execute this
code and you can see there's a a message
right there.
The other type of cell is one like this.
It's kind of like a table or spreadsheet
interface. It runs a formula and then
shows you the result. So, it's a way to
actually run code and see the results
very immediately. And these formulas are
just raw JavaScript with a little
syntactic sugar to figure out, you know,
if you reference something, it knows
what previous table it was.
Let me give you an example of that.
So,
right here is an example. So, here this
get final tokens is just JavaScript code
we defined earlier and this prompt to
tokens is literally the DOM ID and this
let's zoom this one out. This
this bracket is basically syntactic
sugar saying go grab the DOM table that
has this ID. So, prompt to tokens is up
here
and it's just grabbing this thing and
passing that into that function. So,
uh it's all straight vanilla JavaScript,
but the real benefit is being able to
debug a model right here without leaving
your browser. So, what I'm going to do,
I can do
Who here has done like console debugging
before, right?
Right, so you can do console debugging
right here. So, if I say
console.log matches and I open up my dev
tools inspector,
let's put that side by side.
There we go and I go to the console and
then I rerun this.
There we go.
Wait for the layout shifts.
Separate into words is right there.
So, if I rerun this, you can see right
here, it might be a little bit hard, but
if you
look here, you can see I've basically
got my console.log statement here. If I
wanted to know what that variable was
doing, but I can go even further. I can
just type the word debugger
and then I rerun it
and boom, I'm actually stepping through
a large language model that was once
considered too dangerous to release
right without ever leaving my browser.
So, every part of this model, if you
were like, I really want to understand
how this works, you can step right
through it in a familiar language and
the browser, a very familiar IDE.
So, I'm going to remove
that debugger statement
so it doesn't get in our way later.
And then
There we go.
Okay.
So, that's a quick tour of how to run
our JavaScript implementation of GPT-2.
Okay.
Uh next up large language models.
Um so, a large language model has a
really simple job to do.
We give it a passage of text and it
simply predicts the next word.
Technically, the next token as we'll
talk about. So, I might give it the text
Mike is quick, he moves and it'll just
output a single word quickly. It does
not by nature naturally give you
paragraphs of text. So, if we want to
get more text, what we do is we take
that output and then we
append the word we just got out, which
was quickly, and put it at the end of
the thing we originally put in. So, then
we take that additional text, now we ask
it to run through again with this much
longer piece, say what is the next word
now? And it says, "Oh, it's and." Then
we take that, append it to the original
input, and keep going and ask it what
the next thing is. And this is how we
generate paragraphs of text or code for
model. It is what they call an
auto-regressive model. You simply take
the output, put it back to the input,
and rerun it.
Now, this is why if you use our
JavaScript implementation, all it does
is predict the next word because that is
the core function. If you understand
that, you understand how the rest of it
works.
So, we've said that large language
models have this core action of
completing passages of text and they're
trained to complete sentences like this
one. Mike is quick, he moves, and as a
human, you probably understand you know,
a possible completion is the word
quickly or maybe the word fast or
around. But how do we get a computer to
do that?
Well, here's a fill-in-the-blank problem
that computers are really good at. 2 + 2
equals 4. It's a math problem. Computers
are really good at math and you can make
these equations really complex and
computers can still do them really fast.
So, in effect, what researchers have
figured out how to do is take what is a
word problem and turn it into a math
problem.
In order to do that, they have to go
through a series of steps. First, what
they have to do is they have to map the
words in our text to numbers.
Here I've shown it as just a one-to-one
mapping. So, Mike goes to 89, is goes to
nine, but in practice, as we'll see,
it's a long list of numbers called an
embedding.
And then we do our number crunching on
them. Here I've drawn this as just
simple arithmetic. It's much more
complex than that, but it's actually
almost as simple as that. It's just a
lot of multiplication, addition. There's
an exponentiation in there.
Um but it's not math you probably
haven't seen before. It's just a lot of
it tediously put together.
And then after all that arithmetic, we
get a result. Again, it'll be a long
list of numbers. Here I've simplified
for now just saying a single number. And
we look at the resulting number that
comes back and that number is going to
be what it says the next predicted word
is going to be.
But we need to translate that back to a
word cuz it's a number. So, then we do
the reverse of what we did at the
beginning. Instead of going from words
to numbers, we go from numbers to words.
And of course, the number we get back,
numbers are continuous,
words are discrete, doesn't necessarily
always cleanly map. We'll get some
number like here, for example,
hypothetically, we get 231. There's
nothing in our dictionary that maps to
it. But the closest word in our
dictionary is quickly, which is at 232.
But fast is kind of close, too, at 240.
So, what we're going to do is we're
going to weight the probability
distribution of these tokens according
to how close they are to the predicted
number that came out of our model. And
that turns into our probability
distribution. So, then we run a random
number generator and then we pick
according to that distribution. One
thing I want to emphasize is
we add the random number generator in.
We could always just simply take the
closest word and that's called greedy or
temperature zero.
Okay. So, that gives us this view. You
get some text, we turn that text into
tokens, we turn those tokens into
numbers, and then we do some number
crunching on them. And then we turn
those numbers into text.
And that gives us our next predicted
token.
Okay. The model we are going to be
studying today is GPT-2.
Uh GPT-2 small, specifically. There's
actually multiple versions of GPT-2 that
were released. Uh and that came out in
2019, so about 4 years before GPT-4 and
3 years before ChatGPT.
But don't let that fool you. This was a
model that was considered uh too
dangerous to release when it first came
out and was state of the art. More
importantly,
it is actually the foundation of most of
the state-of-the-art models you have
probably used today. And you don't have
to take my word for it. This is a
research lab, EleutherAI, saying
basically,
"The recipe for building a large
language model has not fundamentally
changed since the transformer was
introduced and only slightly tweaked
from the language models by OpenAI GPT-1
and GPT-2."
And then in this article, they actually
go on to list what the changes are
between GPT-2 and uh so and a
state-of-the-art model at the time,
which was Llama 2 when this was written,
which was last year.
So, the way to think about this, and
this is a helpful family tree chart of
different large language models, is that
most of the ones you're familiar with at
the top of this tree, might be hard to
see, is ChatGPT, Llama, Bard/Gemini,
GPT-4, Claude. They all inherit
from GPT-2. GPT-2 is its granddaddy.
If you understand GPT-2, you are 80% of
the way to understanding how a
state-of-the-art model works under the
hood.
Okay. So, now let's dive into the first
stage of our model. So, that's
tokenization.
Okay, this is where we take the input
text and we split it into subword units
called tokens. In the example that I
like to use, Mike is quick, he moves,
unfortunately, every single word is a
single token, but it is not unusual for
a word to be two, three, or more tokens.
And then these tokens all have IDs that
are just lists or positions in the
dictionary, as you see here underneath.
Let me show you what this looks like.
So,
I'll wait for the Wi-Fi.
Okay. Well, we get more people in the
room, we get we get more Wi-Fi
issues.
Um
So, what I want to illustrate for you is
that you can take a word like
oh, you know what I can do? I I do have
a backup.
Let's do this.
Okay, this is the version that runs
locally.
Uh so, what you can do,
so you can try this once we get Wi-Fi
back. I'm going to take the word
reindeer
and the word reinjury
and then I'm going to run them
up until right here, which is the final
tokens.
So, these are the tokens for the input
prompt we just put in here.
And you can see the word reinjury was
turned into multiple tokens. There's a
space, which is part of the token
itself, r e i n, and then jury, j u r y,
and they have separate token IDs. The
thing I want you to pay attention to is
reindeer also starts as r e i n.
Right? But it got split into three
tokens, space r e i n d e e r. So, this
is not like basic string parsing.
Something more complex is going on.
And so, the natural question is, well,
why the heck are we doing this?
Why don't we do something simpler? Why
don't we do, say, word-based
tokenization? We just take every word in
the dictionary and give it a number.
Like dog is one, cat is two, and so
forth. So, that has a couple problems.
First is it can't handle unknown or
misspelled words.
And there are some models, early models
that had an unk for unknown token.
Um but when you're grabbing all the text
on the internet, you might encounter
things you didn't expect. Examples could
be languages that you weren't planning
for.
One of the early models, GPT-2, in fact,
they tried to take foreign languages out
of it. And then they magically
discovered some snuck in and it was
actually good at translation. They
wouldn't have had that if a lot of words
were just simply that were not English
were just thrown out. Another example is
when they did summarization with it,
they realized they can put the too long,
didn't read acronym, tl semicolon dr.
And if they didn't have a token for
that, it would have been thrown away and
it would have lost that ability.
The other problem is that you're going
to increase the vocabulary size, which
is going to increase the size of the
model. It'll need more parameters if
you're going to have more vocabulary.
English alone is 170,000 words. For
perspective, GPT-2's vocabulary is only
about 50,000, so it's 1/3 of that. And
then if you add additional languages on
that and you're doing word-based
tokenization, it would get even larger.
So, in essence, if you do this, you get
more memory, more compute, or maybe less
performance.
So, then you're like, well, I'm a
developer. I'm used to say something
like ASCII. Why don't I just do
character-based tokenization? I say A is
one, B is two, and do it that way. Well,
the first problem is it's going to
increase the sequence length.
So, we can see this inside the model.
As you go through the model, after you
get your prompt
right here, you can see here is where
the embeddings. We'll talk about this in
a second. But you can see Mike is quick.
Period. He moves.
Each of these rows, this matrix,
has a height that is the size of the
number of tokens, right? And that
persists through the entire model. So,
as I keep going, we see again this six
height matrix, it's going to keep going.
If we made every single character its
own token, this is going to get a lot
larger. Right now, it's just what? Six
tokens high. But if I made m i k e, each
of these characters their own token,
this is going to get a much larger
matrix, so it'll be more memory, more
compute to process.
The other issue is there's low semantic
correlation in characters. They don't
carry a lot of meaning.
And a good example is this chain letter
that went around a few decades ago on
the internet. And it says, "According to
research at Cambridge University, it
doesn't matter in what order the letters
in a word are. The only important thing
is that the first and last letter be at
the right place." And all the letters
are jumbled, but you can still read it.
And the point is that you don't read
characters. You actually read sub-word
units yourself. Um and so, if there's
less semantic correlation, it's going to
be more work for the model to do during
training to erase that character
boundary and get the pieces that really
matter.
So, if character tokenization is too
small and word tokenization is too big,
Goldilocks says, "Let's do something in
between," which is sub-word
tokenization. And that's this algorithm
called by pair encoding.
So, it's got two phases. The first is
the learning phase, where you take a
large, they call it a corpus of text
that's gathered from the internet. And
then we put it through this learning
algorithm, we'll describe in a second.
And then we get out of it a vocabulary,
a dictionary of tokens.
And then later, when we're processing
the model and asking it to generate
text, if we give it some input words, we
have to retranslate it into those tokens
that were used during translation during
training.
So, we take the input words, we take the
vocabulary, and we get out tokens.
This is the research paper that
introduced the algorithm to machine
learning, but it turns out this
algorithm is from the '90s. It's
actually a compression algorithm, as
we'll talk about in a second. And it
even has some Python code you can copy
and paste and run.
The goal of the algorithm really is to
take the text that's going to be trained
on and figure out the most efficient way
to represent it. That's really what
tokenization is trying to do.
And so, here's the example from the
paper.
And what I'm going to do first is I'm
going to use this dot to separate out
the characters. Right? That's going to
tell us essentially each token will be
separated by those dots, so we can see
them individually. At the end of this
process, you'll see that there less
dots, meaning that we've got more
tokens, sorry, a large more number of
tokens in our vocabulary, but less
number of tokens being used to represent
the corpus.
And in this corpus, we're going to
pretend that when we scrape the
internet, this is all we came up with.
There are only four words, low, lower,
newest, and widest. And you'll notice
some of them appear more than once, in
fact, they all do. But the reason I'm
doing it this way is I want the
frequency of the word to be represented.
Right? I'm trying to compress all the
the words on the internet. And if a word
is more frequent, I want to know that,
because if it's more frequent, I want to
give it more more representation, or
more efficient representation.
So, that dot is going to separate our
tokens. And then I'm going to put the
underscore to indicate the space
character. One caveat, in this example,
the space character is at the end of the
token. In GPT-2, it's actually at the
beginning.
And then we're going to start with our
vocabulary of just our characters, A
through Z, all lower case. Uh we're
assuming that we're in a lower case
world only here for now. Those are our
initial tokens. That's our vocabulary on
the right.
And then the first thing we're going to
do is we're going to count all the
adjacent tokens, all the adjacent
characters. Right now, it's there are no
tokens other than characters. And we can
see e n s occurs nine times. Right? Six
times in newest and three times in
widest. So, then I'm going to put a
table together and I put e next to s
has a frequency of nine. And then I'm
going to do this for all the possible
pairs. And then I'm going to take the
most frequent pair and I'm going to say
that's a new token. Why am I doing that?
Because if I do that, I can take e n s,
I can put them together, and I can
pretend they're their own character.
I'll call it a token.
And then I can go back to my corpus, and
every place there was an e n s, I'm
going to replace it with my new es
token.
So, now I've shrunk the number of tokens
needed to represent the stuff here on
the left. Now, I've taken what were
separate tokens and combined them
together. So, I'm using less tokens to
represent all this text.
And then I can repeat the process. I can
just say es next to t occurs nine times,
and I can do a whole 'nother table. Now,
es is itself now its own character, its
own token. So, it can be paired with
other things that I'm counting. And I
can see that es with t occurs nine
times. So, I add that to my vocabulary
of tokens, and I go back and I compress
my corpus again.
Then I keep going and I just simply
repeat this process, looking for
whatever is the most frequent at each
pass, and making it a token, and then
recompressing the corpus.
And after 10 passes, you get something
like this. Here on the right is our
vocabulary of tokens.
And then here on the left, you can see
we have shrunk the number of tokens used
to represent the corpus. There are less
of these dots, right, than you we saw
before and originally.
Now, the most frequent words became
their own tokens, right? Low and newest.
And even the words that did not get
their own full token representation were
now represented them a lot more
efficiently.
Uh and you notice that there's some
common sub-word units like low became
tokens and est became tokens. So, it
managed to map to some of the morphemes,
the parts of speech we use as humans as
tokens, but that is just a coincidence.
Right now, the model has no
understanding of semantic meaning.
Okay. So, this is the learning
algorithm.
Now, the tokenization algorithm is
really similar. I'm not going to go
through it in full detail. I have a
video on my YouTube channel where I do
go through it in full detail, but for
time, I'm just going to talk about it at
a high level. It's essentially similar
to the learning algorithm, except we're
doing it on individual tokens as they
come in, asking ourselves, "What would
it look like if this word were part of
the tokenization process?" Let me show
you what that is like. So, this is a
helpful jump to here. Let's go to
tokenization. So, the first thing we do
is we take our prompt and we separate it
into words. Now, this is just a regular
expression that came from the OpenAI
source code when they open sourced it.
And we're just parsing it according to
this, and it's going to basically take
out punctuation and spaces. So, we get
these as our words.
So, Mike is quick. Period gets its own
token. He and moves. Right now, we're
not tokens, we're just separating
towards. But do note that the spaces are
assigned as part of the separation. So,
he and moves have a space in front of
them.
The next thing we do is we're going to
fetch vocab.bpe.
This is a file that came from OpenAI
when they trained the model in its
tokenization. This is their dictionary
of tokens. So, here's when they did
their training in BP, the most common
left token with a right token was space
with a t. The second most was space
followed by an a, and so forth. I've
added two extra columns, rank and score,
just to figure out where
uh a pair of tokens is in terms relative
to the others, how important they were.
Then this is just a helpful map of
tokens to their IDs.
And then finally, there's this, which is
prompt to tokens. Now, this is not how
you'd really want to write a tokenizer.
I've set it up to look similar to the
Excel version of the matrix, so you can
watch the video and still be able to
watch it and and understand it depending
no matter which version of uh the Excel
sheet or the JavaScript version you're
looking at. But this kind of illustrates
the process. So, here is quick. We're
breaking it apart right here.
Let me get Presentify.
There we go. We're breaking it apart
into characters here.
Right? Quick. And then, what we're doing
is we're looking at each pair of
characters. So, Q with U, U with I, I
with C, C with K, and we're saying, "For
each one, where does it fall in that
rank of tokens?" And we're going to take
the most popular one. In this case, it's
I and C. And so, we've rewritten this as
a string of tokens, except the I and C
were put together as one token. And
then, we're simply going to repeat the
process.
Let's stop annotation.
And keep going, and we'll combine then Q
and U get combined, then I C K get
combined, and finally gets to the point
where we realize, "Oh, this isn't my
token vocabulary." And it turns it into
a token. Again, I have video if you want
to see this in in-depth and in detail.
Um
but for now, just think of it as the
same part of the learning process.
Really just run
small. Now, tokenization is actually
kind of considered by a lot of experts
to be a necessary evil. Some of the
problems that you sometimes encounter
with models, although the root cause
isn't tokenization, it can sometimes
make them worse. So, the common one is,
"How many R's are there in strawberry?"
Uh models don't actually see the R's.
And I love this, you know, post from
Riley Goodside, where if you remember
the Matrix, the character says, "Oh, I
don't I don't see the numbers. I just
see, you know, there." And that's kind
of like what it is to the model. You
know, it doesn't see any of the letters.
So, what he's done here in this image is
strawberry is tokenized multiple
different ways, depending on whether
it's uppercase versus lowercase, whether
there's a space in front of it or not,
and whether there's a uh quote in front
of it or not. So, to the model, you
know, these six words are not all
strawberry. They're all six different
token patterns. And so, it makes it a
lot harder and a lot more work for the
model to understand it. think about it,
you don't actually see the letters
either. If somebody asked you how many
letters are in a word, you'd have to
stop and think and parse it out.
Um I said at the beginning, you know,
you don't want to do word tokenization,
you don't want to do character
tokenization. That's not a hard fast
rule. That's an empirical rule. And
there are research models that have done
both. Uh so, just know that, you know,
that's, you know, maybe a few years from
now that we character-based tokenization
will be more popular. This is an example
of one.
The last thing I want to leave you with
is that tokenization doesn't have to be
just about uh text. It can also be about
other things. So, here's an example of
Vision Transformer. They use patches of
images as tokens. Waymo uses uh
trajectories in space to prevent
collisions as tokens.
Okay.
Let's briefly check
how we're doing, if this will load.
There we go. So, this is actually pinned
at the top. Uh 9:30 Oh, we're right
We're just a minute behind. Okay. So,
this is You guys can keep me honest. Uh
at in the Discord room at the top is a
spreadsheet. I'm of course using a
spreadsheet to make sure we stay on
track and on time.
Uh okay.
So, oh, we need to do this now.
There we go. Next up is embeddings. So,
now we're in the second phase of the
input. Uh these are uh
token and position embeddings.
Okay. So, at the beginning of this
workshop, I talked about how we map
words into numbers, and I simplified
this process by saying what we're doing
is we're taking, say, the word Mike and
we're turning into a single number, uh
like 89. But of course, that's not what
we're really doing.
We're actually going to turn it into a
long list of numbers called an
embedding. Um so, even the period, for
example, gets 768 of these numbers. And
in the case of GPT-2, uh the
dimensionality, that list size, is 768.
Every single word gets 768 numbers, and
you can see that if we go to
the token embedding section.
And then, these We'll get to that table
in a second.
These are the embeddings of our input
prompt. And you can type By the way, I I
didn't mention this before. You can type
anything here in this input prompt, and
it should parse it, although it doesn't
handle foreign languages well, because
there's a character mismatch on their
part. Um but here's Mike is quick
. And each of these gets 768
numbers. So, what you can do is if I
take row one, column 768,
there's where our list of 768 numbers
ends. So, every single one of these gets
the same number of
uh
dimensions for how it gets represented.
And it might be a little confusing, cuz
we mapped words into tokens with numbers
that had token IDs, and then we have
these embeddings as well. And the
analogy I like to use is imagine you are
going to go uh look for a house to rent
or a house to buy. And the street
addresses uh and you build this table of
street addresses and square feet,
bedrooms, and bathrooms, and price. The
street addresses are identifiers.
They're kind of like the token IDs. They
tell you where to find something, where
to find a house, but they don't tell you
anything about what's inside. They don't
tell you about what you care about, what
the meaning is. Doesn't tell you the
square feet, the bedrooms, the
bathrooms, or the price. And the
embedding values, that's their job.
They're to take the token and tell you
something about what it means. And the
identifier or the token ID is just to
tell give it a position in the
dictionary, effectively a numerical
name.
And what we're really doing with the
embedding values is we're trying to
build a map for words, where we put
similar words grouped together. So, here
I've shown a two-dimensional map, but of
course, we're in a 768
hyperdimensional area. But the idea is
basically the same. Take the words happy
and glad in this map, this word island.
You know, those are happy words, so I'm
going to put them up here.
And then, I'm going to take words like
dog and cat, and I'll put them in
another part of this word island,
because they're animals. They They don't
relate as much. And then, you know, the
word sad, well, it doesn't have the same
meaning as happy and glad, but it's
still an emotion. So, I want it closer
to the emotions happy emotions part of
the island, into this, maybe the sad
province, right next to the happy
province. They're kind of on the same
half of the island, but they're not
directly in the same spot, because happy
and sad have different meanings.
So, here's a simple two-dimensional
example of the benefit of doing this,
which is that you can start doing word
arithmetic and word math. So, we're
going to imagine that we've built a
two-dimensional embedding, where the
first column is authority, and the
second column is gender. And we take the
token man, and we'll just arbitrarily
say, "Man has authority of one and a
gender of one, a woman authority of one
and a gender of two. A king has more
authority than a man, so two for
authority, gender of one, because still
a man, and then queen authority of two
and a gender of two." And we can plot
this out in a plane like as follows. So,
queen, for example, is at position two,
two.
And then, we can actually build
relationships just from doing vector
math. So, for example, if we take king,
we subtract man, we add woman, and then
we just do regular arithmetic column by
column. So, 2 - 1 + 1, 1 - 1 + 2 gives
us
two, two. So, king - man + woman is two,
two, but of course, that is the same
thing as queen. So, we're saying king -
man + woman = queen.
And we can think of this as an analogy.
King is to man as queen is to woman.
And if we take out the queen and just
leave it as a blank,
we have our first kind of word problem
we can convert to a math problem. If you
give me any three words and I had an
embedding for them, I can figure out
what the fourth word in this
relationship is simply from vector math.
And that is what Word2vec, which was the
most famous word embedding, was able to
do. It learned a bunch of relationships
um in a series of papers, not just one
paper. Uh so, for example, France
is to Paris as Italy is to Rome and
Japan is to Tokyo. Einstein is to
scientist as Messi is to midfielder, or
Mozart is to violinist. Uh Japan is to
sushi as Germany is to bratwurst. It
didn't get all of them right, but
clearly it's learning something about
relationships. And I want to be clear,
this is actually just the same thing as
being good at clustering. So, imagine
I've got on my word island, I've got all
my countries over here, right? France,
Japan, Italy.
And then, I've got all my capitals,
Paris, Tokyo, Rome, over here in the
word island. Well, every single one of
them has the same vector relationship in
space between each other, if the
clustering was really good and tight.
And if somebody comes in and says, "Hey,
what's the capital of Canada?" Well, I
just use that same direction, I add that
same vector to it, and I can say, "Oh,
well, it's Ottawa."
So, in practice, real-world embeddings
are different than what I've shown here
with this contrived example. First of
all, we have many more columns or
dimensions. So, instead of simply two,
we have hundreds. GPT-2 is 768. Your
state-of-the-art model these days has a
lot more.
Uh the other key difference is I made up
this thing saying that the first
dimension or column is authority, the
second one is gender. We don't know what
they mean. The columns are completely
uninterpretable. The model just seems to
pick them. And the values themselves,
correspondingly therefore, are not
interpretable, either.
And that might sound useless, but it's
actually useful for at least getting
similarity, for example. So, let's go
back to our housing analogy. Imagine I
took off the top column, The the labels
essentially, top row uh of what each
column meant and I just gave you the
IDs.
If you went to say 47 Ivy Lane and you
said I like this house, I want to see
more like it, you could still find
those. Because what you could do is you
could notice that with 58 Sun Ave and 15
Luna Lane, they all have roughly the
same values in the first column, 2400,
2400, 2400 and the same values for the
third, fourth column as well.
So you're like, if I like this house, I
can find the others like it even though
I don't know what these columns mean.
So the question you're probably asking
yourself is, well, where the heck do
these values come from? How do we know
what they mean or how does the model
pick it?
Well, the slightly unsatisfying answer
is that the embeddings are just simply
learned by the neural network model
during training. So now let's just talk
about what training looks like. So in
training, what we do is we grab a bunch
of text from the internet, we take out
passages like this one, Mike is quick,
he moves quickly. So quickly was in the
original passage.
And then we chop off the last token or
the last word and we have a randomly
initialized model. All the values of the
weights and parameters are completely
random, including the embeddings. And
then we run it through the whole model
and we say, what do you predict is going
to be the next word and it's random. So
it comes up with some nonsensical like,
Mike is quick, he moves haircut. And
then we use this
algorithm called back propagation and we
say, hey back propagation, the correct
answer was quickly. Can you adjust the
parameters to get closer to that value?
And it will go and tell us for every
single parameter how to slightly move it
to get it closer to producing the right
answer of quickly. And then we rerun the
model and eventually it says, Mike is
quick, he moves quickly. And then we do
this not just for one single passage of
text, we're doing this for many passages
at a time. And one great benefit of this
is we don't have to teach the model
anything explicitly. It's kind of
learning from unsupervised text we're
just gathering that was naturally there
on the internet and it's learning things
like grammar, names, capitals of
countries.
Um but that seems a bit mysterious and
we can kind of get an intuitive sense
for what it's doing if you think about
it as learning from word statistics. So
imagine you've got passages like this
one about the words ice and steam. It
was so cold, the puddle had turned to
ice. Steam rose from the still hot cup
of coffee. And what you notice is that
the words ice and cold tend to co-occur
with each other. And the words steam and
hot tend to co-occur with each other. So
if you were an alien coming down from
another planet, you had no idea what our
language was and you looked at this, you
would say, I don't know what ice, cold,
steam and hot are. But I know that ice
is probably called more than steam is
because ice and cold co-occur more often
than steam and cold do. And I know that
steam is hot because ice and hot don't
co-occur as much as steam and hot do. So
there there must be some relationship,
they must have that meaning.
And this is called the distributional
hypothesis. Uh and the phrase that is
you'll often hear people quote is, you
shall know a word by the company it
keeps, which is basically that a word is
partially defined by its context or said
another way, words that have similar
meanings can be replaced with each other
in similar contexts.
So if you know how they're distributed
in their statistical representation, you
have a sense of what similar words might
be.
And in fact, in my the full version of
my class, we actually build our own
primitive embeddings from Wikipedia
pages using a very simplified version of
not word2vec, but another algorithm
called glove, which is based on just
using a co-occurrence matrix. So roughly
what that process looks like is you
would count how often the words co-occur
within some window size inside your
corpus of text. You'd analyze every
single word and you'd look in this case
three words to the left, three words to
the right and you'd say, these are the
words that co-occur with it. And then
you'd build a big giant table, a matrix
and you'd say, let me compare every word
to every other word and I'm going to
count how often they co-occur in all my
text with each other. So here in this
example, word two and word three
co-occur, let's say five times in our
corpus of text.
And then what you can think of the
embedding as, instead of taking this
table which is all possible words by all
possible words and if we're in English,
that's about 170,000 words or in the
case of BPE, it's 50,000 tokens, you can
imagine it compressing the columns of
the matrix. So instead of having 170,000
columns, it's got whatever your
embedding dimension is, 768. It's still
all possible words high,
but it's now a lot smaller in the number
of columns.
So it's basically a compressed
co-occurrence matrix. So the actual
table OpenAI gives us from training, the
embedding table, is really just this
thing on the right. It is basically
every single word or token and then the
representation of its dimensions. And
you can think of it as they just took a
co-occurrence matrix and they shrunk it.
The reason I like this mental model is
it helps motivate certain things about
embeddings that might seem a bit weird.
So a classic one is how do you measure
how similar two embeddings are? You
might naively think we just look at
Euclidean space, you know, as the crow
flies, how far apart they are. But
that's not what we do, we use something
called cosine similarity. How many
people have heard of cosine similarity?
Yeah, so
you know, cosine similarity is not an
intuitive measurement of similarity. And
what it is is we take the angle of the
two points and then we take the cosine
of that angle and that's how we say how
similar two embeddings are. So if they
are, if you remember your trigonometry,
if they're opposed, you know, cosine
goes from -1 to 1, so if they're
opposed, they get -1 value, so that's
when two vectors are like this. If
they're unrelated, it's like this,
they're orthogonal and if they're
similar, they're pointing the same
place, the cosine will be 1. Oh and by
the way, this opposite is not opposite
in probably our intuitive conventional
sense. So happy and sad, you might think
would be opposites, but actually they're
more similar to each other than any
other set of words.
Um if you think about how often like
happy and sad probably occur in songs
and poems and other types of context,
they're both emotions. So they're
actually more similar than they would be
opposite. In fact, if you take all the
GPT-2 um embeddings and you compare them
against each other, very few are
negative and most of those are close to
zero.
Um but going back to kind of learning
from word statistics, the key thing we
care about is the relative co-occurrence
of different words against each other.
We don't care about the the raw
co-occurrence. So let's for example
imagine there's this section of our
co-occurrence matrix, which is the basis
for the embeddings. We're comparing
three words, one, two, three, against
word 10 and 11.
And word one occurs with word 10 and
word 11 10 times each. Word two occurs
with word 10 and 11 50 times each. Word
three on the other hand is five and 20
times. And I'm going to plot these as
vectors where the horizontal axis how
many times it occurs with word 10 and
the vertical is how many times with word
11.
And what we notice
is something interesting. Word one and
two essentially have the same meaning.
As far as word 10 and word 11 can tell,
the relative probability between them is
the same, one to one. It's just that
word two happens to be more common,
right? It's five times more common.
But if we plotted this in vector space,
what you see is that word two and word
one are really far apart in Euclidean
distance, but they have the same angle.
Now word three is actually closer in
Euclidean space, but relative to word 10
and word 11 has a different meaning. And
so that's a motivation for why we're
looking at the angle, right? Which seems
to more accurately capture the meaning
and not necessarily popularity, which is
what Euclidean space would capture.
Okay, so how do we actually use this?
Well, these embeddings were learned
during training. So OpenAI gives us this
model_wte
matrix and the way it's set up is that
it is our vocabulary size tall, so
50,257
tokens is how many tokens GPT-2 uses. So
there's a row for every single token and
then each row is just simply the
embedding for that token. So there's a
row for dog and that row is the 768
numbers that represent the semantic
meaning of dog. So let's go to our
example here. So let's take is.
Uh what is the token ID for is? It is
318.
So this is our model WTE. This is one of
those CSV files we dragged in. So it
fetches it and it displays it. So let's
go to row 318. There's actually an off
by one, but I'll do that anyways.
So you can see, we'll pull come back to
that in a second and let's go to our
final token embeddings right here. Uh so
is, you can see it's 0.0097,
0.010
and you'll see that matches what you
have here. 0.0097
in the 319th row, but if we were zero
indexed, it'd be 318. 0.001.
So all this code is doing right here is
it's grabbing the token ID and just
pulling out the corresponding row and
plopping it into this table here. So
it's a very simple operation, that's why
this is what? Uh
basically 15 lines of JavaScript to just
grab one thing out of another and then
put it here. So all this is doing is
just taking those token IDs and looking
them up and putting them in this table.
Uh last thing I want to say before we
leave token embeddings is as before with
tokens, I said it doesn't just have to
be a text. Uh the same thing is true for
embeddings. So the famous example is
CLIP, which is the basis for a lot of
the image generators that you probably
have tried or used and instead of just
comparing words against words, you can
think of it as it's comparing words
against images. So if you look at all
the images on the internet, you look at
that alt text and it sees dog and a
bunch of images with dogs in it, you can
get it to learn that relationship. So
later on, you can pass an image and it
can say this thing is a dog.
Okay, let's go to position embeddings.
Okay, so now we're still at the top with
input and we're talking about uh
embeddings, but now we're talking about
a different kind of embedding.
And the key thing to remember is that in
English, word order matters, right? The
dog chases the cat is something
different than the cat chases the dog.
Now, in math, 2 + 3 = 5, but 3 + 2 = 5.
Anything after that equal sign has no
idea what the order was.
Our problem is that when we mapped
from a word domain, an English domain, a
language domain, we were in a domain
where order typically matters, we went
to a number domain where order typically
does not matter. And even though I've
drawn this with simplified arithmetic,
there are parts of the model that are
also commutative. So, what could happen
in essence is you can change the order
of the words, right? And now it could
mean something different or could be
completely gibberish. But anything after
that equal sign can't tell the
difference.
So, it has no sense of position of these
words and that's going to be really hard
to understand the meaning of the
sentence or the phrase.
So, what we're going to do is we're
going to add some sense of position to
the embedding.
What we're going to do is we're going to
just take for example one token like
woman and say woman at position zero in
the prompt is going to basically mean
the same thing as woman at any other
position in the prompt. So, let's give
woman at one position a
other than zero a slight offset, a
slightly different position to represent
that it's roughly the same meaning, it's
just woman when it occurs at position
one and then different spot for woman at
position two and so forth. And in
general, we'll use the position in the
prompt to define a small offset that
we're going to slightly move the
position of the token in the embedding
space.
In the original famous attention is all
you need paper, they used the sine and
cosine formulas.
Uh you don't have to look through the
whole thing. The key thing I want you to
pay attention to is it's just sine and a
cosine. And if you remember your
trigonometry, sine and cosine goes from
-1 to 1. So, what we're effectively
doing is we are building this circle
right around this with a limited
diameter and we're saying I'm
oscillating if and that's the other
thing to remember from trigonometry is
that sine and cosine oscillate. I'm just
oscillating the position of this thing
in space based on its position in the
prompt. I'm keeping it roughly in that
same area, but it's a little cloud
that's all the different versions of
woman just in different parts of the
prompt.
In GPT-2, interestingly enough, uh they
didn't use that same technique. They let
the model learn the embeddings on its
own, which still blows my mind.
Um so, how we use this is we have
another matrix that
uh OpenAI gives us when they open source
GPT-2, which is the position matrix. And
this time it is 1024 high, which is our
maximum context length. Not it's an
early model, so it's not very large
context.
Um and then each of the rows is again
the embedding dimension. And what we're
going to do is these are position
offsets. So, we're going to add these
offsets in each row to each
value in our embedding dimension to
offset it to represent its position. So,
you can think of it like this, we start
with our embedding values
from the token embeddings and then we're
basically doing a matrix add. So, we're
taking
each of these elements here, so I take
this element and add it to this one,
this element added to this one, this one
added to that one. We're just simple
element-wise add and that gets our
position embeddings for every single one
of our input tokens.
So, let me show you where that is.
Okay, so the first thing we do is we
fetch this model_wpe.
Um that again comes from OpenAI. You can
see this is 1024. So, if we go to row
1024, column one,
there it is. That's our max context
length.
So, beyond that, the model has no idea
how to solve it, understand that. You
can ignore this one. And the this code
for positional embed is really just a
matrix add. The only thing I have to do
is make sure well, the input token uh
input prompt is going to be less than
1024 tokens. So, it just needs to stop
when it gets to the end of the input.
But that gives us our positional
embeddings here. So, we're just passing
to this our token embeddings we had from
the previous step and then our model WPE
table, which came fetched from the CSV
file. It just simply adds those together
and we get these positional embeddings.
Uh here's kind of an illustration of the
action of GPT-2 uh and its positional
embeddings. So, these numbers you see
right after like happy three, happy
four, aren't the actual tokens. What
I've done is I've plotted the word happy
uh the token happy rather and I've put
it at different positions. I put it
position three, position four, position
five and so forth. And then I took two
other words, happy and glad, and I just
put them in spaces as reference points.
And you can see it's doing what we
described earlier. It's basically just
keeping it roughly in the same position.
It's slightly offsetting it depending on
where it is in the prompt.
Uh one key thing you should know, of all
the changes to, you know, modern LLMs
from GPT-2, probably one of the most
common and biggest ones is that they do
not use these types of positional
embeddings. They do something called
rope. Um so, if you look at a a modern
LLM, this is probably the first thing
you'll see that's different.
Okay.
Let's do a time check.
We are
we are 5 minutes behind, but we've got
10 minutes. I will take a break for a
question or two if anybody wants to ask
one.
Any questions so far?
Yeah, go ahead.
Oh, there's a microphone right there.
Uh you were mentioning that with GPT-2,
they weren't using the sine and cosine
kind of cloud. Like what were they
actually doing to come up with the word
position embeddings?
Uh that's the crazy thing. They
they let the model learn it. So, the big
change they did is
think of it this way.
If we go back to our
uh
diagram of how embeddings are learned,
right here.
Right?
Okay, so
in the original transformer, the
position embeddings were not represented
as learnable weights, right? They were
sine and cosine functions. All they did
is they said during backpropagation,
let's learn those as well.
And that's how it learned them.
Uh so, they did not uh they just simply
said hey, let's not hardcode those
values and let's make that other thing
now a parameter the model learns.
Okay, good question.
And as I said, it's still kind of
mind-blowing that that worked.
Uh but as we now know, these things can
learn a ton.
Okay.
Let's talk about attention.
Okay, there we go. So, now we're getting
into the heart of the number crunching.
And this one's going to be a little more
cursory understanding
uh and explanation, but I still think
it's important to understand what it is.
Um and we're going to start with
attention.
And now we're inside what are often
called the layers. I like to call them
the blocks. That's a less common, but
other people use the term blocks. The
reason I use the word blocks is when I
teach this, it's usually people coming
to it the first time and the word layer
gets used in other contexts. Later,
we're going to talk about the
multi-layer perceptron and it can be
confusing when you're first coming to
something and the same word has
different meanings depending on the
context. But know that when you talk to
most people when they talk about how
many layers are model, they're talking
about what I call how many blocks.
And if you
start getting to this part of the code,
you'll notice that inside the blocks,
actually if you go right here,
you can see these are all labeled with
steps, step 1 2 4 9 10. So, this step
number is arbitrary.
Um you can do it in fewer steps, you can
do it in more steps. This is what I
happened to pick when I was implementing
it in Excel and I kept the same mapping
so all my material would translate. Um
attention is steps four through nine.
So, there's a lot of steps in here. Um
but the key operations inside the blocks
are multi-head attention and the
multi-layer perceptron. So, let's talk
about attention.
And I'll talk about it mostly
conceptually.
Um the way to think about attention is
we're going to let the tokens or words
talk to each other so they can convey
their meaning to all the other words.
So, for example, he is a pronoun, its
antecedent Mike is in the sentence,
maybe it needs to find that guy and
realize, oh, Mike is my antecedent as
opposed to say, you know, if there was a
name Sally, that's unlikely to be the
match of it.
But there's other kinds of ways words
can communicate to disambiguate. So, for
example, the word quick in English has
four different meanings. It can mean
moving fast in physical space, but it
can also mean bright as in quick of wit.
It can be a body part as in the quick of
your fingernail. And in Shakespearean
English, it can be uh alive as in the
phrase the quick and the dead.
And knowing that this word moves here
helps the model understand that, oh,
we're probably talking about quick when
it's physical space. It helps it predict
what the next word could be. Could be
fast, it could be moves around, right?
But it's not, you know, a body part or
your fingernail.
And the way I like to think about
attention is we've got these tokens,
these words, and they're sitting in this
embedding space, and I like to imagine
there's kind of a a weird gravity, like
celestial mechanics, where each of these
tokens in attention now suddenly look at
what position they're at, and they're
able to push and pull each other
relative to a kind of gravity. And if
you remember, gravity is mass times
distance. So, you've probably heard of
query, key, and value, and there's kind
of this file cabinet analogy, but I feel
like it doesn't capture kind of all the
level of interaction between the tokens
that's really happening. And what's
happening is, you know, if you remember,
gravity is mass times distance, the
distance I like to think of is a measure
of relevance. So, quick and moves,
whenever they see each other, they're
like, "Oh, yeah, you and you, we should
talk to each other." But quick and the
period, they probably don't need to talk
to each other a lot, and that's kind of
like distance in terms of gravity. And
then I like to think of the value as
being kind of like mass, the kind of
action they're going to exert on each
other.
And what's happening is, let's go back
to what we talked about with embeddings.
We've got moves, which is sitting
somewhere in the embedding space.
And if you remember that co-occurrence
matrix, moves has been used in a lot of
sentences. In some sentences, moves was
used to describe rabbits, right? Or
cheetahs, or
animals or things that moved fast. So,
there's some other point in this
embedding space
that we don't have yet that represents
moves in a fast context. And then moves
was used in some sentences to describe
slugs or penguins. And so, moves in that
case was implying slow. But the
embedding for moves, unfortunately, has
to capture all of those meanings
together. But now that we know quick is
here,
we can change that. We can say, "Oh, I'm
going to shift the position of moves
from the regular generic version of
moves to the moves fast." So, I've kind
of disambiguated the word. I've shifted
its position in space to capture its
meaning.
Um I'm not going to go through all the
steps of attention, but I think the most
salient part of attention to see
is um
step seven.
The most famous thing that people
usually show.
Right here.
So, you can see it says, "Mike is
quick." on the horizontal, and then
"Mike is quick." period, "He moves." on
the vertical. So, what this is is you
can see how much relevance or attention
each word is paying to every other word.
And by the way, what you're seeing here
is just the first head, there are
multiple of these heads. So, if you
scroll this to the right 64 spaces,
you'll see another matrix that looks
like this.
And uh there's a couple of things to
notice. The the biggest thing to notice
here is that
uh the upper triangle is all zeros, and
that's because in
transformers like GPT-2 and
decoder-based transformers, we have this
rule that no token can look forward,
they can only look at the tokens before
it. Those are the ones that can
influence it. And then the other key
property is each of these values, each
row, sums up to one. So, you can think
about the percentage of attention each
word is paying to the other tokens. So,
here, for example, moves, right? 16% of
its attention here in the first head of,
in this case, the last block is paying
16% of its attention to the word Mike,
23% of its attention to is, and so
forth.
Okay. Next up, the multi-layer
perceptron. Okay, so now this is the
second major operation inside each block
or layer. Uh and the reason I want to
cover this in a little more detail is I
want to explain what a neural network
is, and it helps give a little more
understanding to how the model actually
learns, the key algorithm called
backpropagation. So, if you haven't seen
a neural network before, it is a
computational model inspired by the
human brain, it is not a direct mimic or
simulation of how the brain works.
Inside the brain, we have these things
called neurons. These neurons are all
connected to each other, and you've got
a bunch of connections incoming from
other neurons, and you've got a bunch of
connections outgoing to other neurons.
And then in between, you have this
axon right here.
And the axon has an all or nothing
activation behavior. If there's a
sufficient amount of pattern of input
that shows up, the axon will activate,
and it will send a signal out to its
output.
But if the activation doesn't have
enough meet some threshold, you'll have
these failed initiations, and no signal
will be sent to the output. It'll be
completely silent. As far as the other
output neurons connected, this neuron is
not firing. Something, you know, the
signal wasn't getting through.
And so, we model this mathematically uh
with this diagram, where we've got a
bunch of inputs, X1 through Xn, and
these are just numbers. Uh these will be
our embedding dimension numbers. And
then we've got another series of numbers
called weights, W1, W2 through Wn, and
we're simply multiplying the X's times
the W's, adding them together, adding an
additional another number called a bias
term, and then we put it through an
activation function. And this activation
function is designed to roughly mimic
what happens in the brain. The easiest
one to understand is this one, ReLU,
which is basically saying when I
multiply and add all the inputs coming
in against their weights, if the result
is negative, then I do do nothing. It
comes out as zero. Um if it's positive,
then I just pass it through as is.
There's a whole zoo of these activation
functions.
So, then what we do is we take these
neurons, and we stitch them together
into a network of neurons, hence an
artificial neural network. Now, there's
a lot of ways you can stitch these
together. In the case of
uh transformers and GPT-2, we do it in a
pattern called the multi-layer
perceptron. You will also see it
referred to as a fully connected network
and uh a feedforward neural network, or
just simply the neural network. Um it is
called by all these terms. These are not
directly identical terms, but they all
overlap.
And the way the MLP pattern looks is you
have your neurons arranged in these
columns of neurons, and these are called
layers. And each layer in the
multi-layer perceptron has a node, and
nodes in each layer can are fully
connected to every other node in its
preceding input, but no other. So, this
node right here can see all of its
inputs nodes. It's all connected to all
of them, but it cannot talk to any of
these directly. Everything that it gets
is mediated through this intermediate
layer between it. And these layers
between the input and the output are
simply just called hidden layers.
Uh the last thing maybe you should know
as background on this is that neural
networks can be more efficient to write
as a matrix multiplication. So, this
process, got two neurons with a set of
weights, so W1 W11 * X1, W21 * X2 + B.
This is can be written as a matrix
multiplication, where you just separate
all the weights into one matrix, all the
inputs into one matrix, and all the
biases into one matrix, and then you can
write it as this large W * X + B
um
equals the representation of the same
thing of running a bunch of these
neurons together. If you don't know your
matrix multiplication, I'm I like this
website, um which has a nice interactive
visual demonstration of what matrix
multiplication looks like.
So, you hit this, and then you keep
going through step, and you can kind of
convince yourself that what I showed
here matches what's on that webpage.
So, the key property though of what and
why MLPs are so important is that they
are universal trainable approximators to
any function purely from its input and
output. With enough neurons, an MLP can
approximate almost any function.
So, let's just take a simple example
like a parabola, and we're going to
imagine we're going to use a simple
neural network with a ReLU activation to
try and approximate it. We'll have one
input node, one output, cuz we have an X
going into a Y, and then let's just use
two nodes in our hidden layer. And those
two nodes will use a ReLU activation.
Well, without doing the math, you can
kind of imagine just by matching shapes
how you might do this. I'll take the
ReLU, and I can take this part of the
ReLU, and I can match it to the right
half of my parabola. And then I can take
another ReLU, I can flip it, and then I
can match it to the left half.
And then I can add them together, and
I've got some kind of approximation to
my parabola, at least on this
domain of X that we're looking at.
And that's what I've done in this
example here.
Which.
Let's see if the Wi-Fi behaves for us.
There we go. So, here you can actually
do this simple neural network, and you
can try to match it to a parabola, and
you can interactively move this.
And you can see, and this is a measure
of error up here called mean square
error. You can try and see how good you
can get your level of error. And you can
see the action here. We're basically
changing the different line pieces that
we're using that are made out of ReLUs
to try and match this parabola. This can
kind of give you a
a feel for what the model is actually
trying to do when it's trying to match a
function.
And you can think of this like more
neurons means more lines, which means a
better approximation. So, with eight
neurons, the parabola looks like this.
With 20 neurons, it looks like this.
With 200 neurons, you can barely tell
the difference, at least at this scale.
But the other key thing is that we don't
have to use trial and error to find this
out, especially once you get 200
neurons. Imagine doing what I was doing
with that fiddling.
Um oh, uh so, this is a theorem. With
enough neurons that you can approximate
almost any function. It's called the
universal approximation theorem, but the
key thing is you combine that with a
special algorithm called
backpropagation,
which lets us learn any function purely
from its inputs and outputs without
having to twiddle twiddle those knobs,
it'll do it for us.
And that's important, because what we're
going to ask this multi-layer perceptron
to do is the core mechanism job of a
transformer, which is I'm going to give
it a word. I'm going to give it the
embedding of a token. And I'm going to
ask it predict what the embedding of the
next token is.
I don't know what that function is. But
I can grab text on the internet and I
can grab one word and I can grab the
word that comes after it and I can give
it to the perceptron and I can say learn
from this input and output what that
mapping function is, as crazy as it
might be. And what will happen is
backpropagation will look at the input,
it'll look at the output we got from the
model when it was initially randomized,
it'll look at the ground truth from what
came pulled from the internet, and it
will look at how we need to adjust the
parameters and weights to change the
perceptron to get more accurate at
making that prediction. And after enough
iterations, it'll get better and better
and actually we get begin to start
matching the function.
Um
the canonical analogy to understand
what's happening in backpropagation,
also known as for our purposes gradient
descent, is a lost hiker trying to get
down a foggy mountain.
Um and you're at the top of this foggy
mountain as a hiker. I've actually been
in this situation. And you can't see any
of the landscape, so you don't know
which direction to go to get off the
mountain.
Well, the one thing you can do is you
can look down at the ground and you can
say, "Oh, whichever way is going down,
uh that's going to be the area of of
towards getting off the mountain." By
the way, actually in real life, I've
tried this, it does not work. Uh this is
how I got lost. Um so uh this is a hiker
representing uh the hiker in this
analogy represents the model parameters.
It's in some space, but we don't know
where to move the model parameters to
get the least amount of error. And the
mountain represents the error. It
represents how wrong we are at the
current position of where the hiker is
or where the parameters are. And the
mountain is foggy because we can tell
the amount of error when I give it an
input and it makes a prediction for the
next token and we compare it, we can
say, "Oh, it's wrong." But we don't know
how to shift the model parameters to get
low lower error. But calculus will give
us that slope. It'll tell us where the
elevation is going down. It won't tell
us what the whole mountain looks like,
but it'll just say where you are
standing right now, go in this direction
and you'll decrease the amount of error
you've got. And you use that to find
your way down the mountain, so to speak,
of the parameters and find a minimum.
So, that brings us to the MLP stage. Uh
it's steps 13, 14, and 15 in the model.
So, let's go back here.
So, uh
you can see all the formulas here. What
I'm going to do is going to show you
them in slide form.
And I'm going to graphically show what's
happening in the uh GPT-2 MLP stage. So,
GPT-2's MLP has only one hidden layer.
The input layer right here
has 768 of these X inputs. Why? Because
we're going to give it an embedding.
We're going to say give Here's the
embedding and predict it. So, I'm going
to give it 768 numbers of the preceding
token that I want it to predict
afterwards, and then its output layer is
768 numbers for the predicted embedding
token. So, input and output are 768,
they're our embedding dimension. And
then it's got one hidden layer, which is
bigger. This ratio of four times the
embedding dimension turns out to be
empirically useful and lots of models do
it, but I don't know if you could figure
that out just uh from first principles,
it's kind of empirically been
determined.
And we have three steps here for
applying our weights and bias, applying
our activation function, which in this
case is the GELU activation function,
and then we project that back down to
our embedding dimension. So,
you can think of it this way, we take
our embeddings from a previous step,
and then what we're doing is we're
taking those embedding values and we're
going to send each embedding value into
its position inside the MLP,
and then we run it through the model,
and then these are now the embedding
values that come out are the embedding
values of the predicted token.
And then we take the next token in our
prompt and then run it through the MLP
again. In practice, you do this in
parallel, but conceptually you can think
of it this way as happening one after
the other.
Okay, so what's happening in these three
steps is really just a combination of
matrix add and multiply. So, we take the
result of our previous step, which is
step 12, which I've not gone into. Um
and then we have some learned weight
matrix, which you see as MLP FC weights,
that's the how they decided to name it.
And we multiply those. So, here's our
matrix multiply.
And then we add it to another bias
matrix.
So, where in this matrix multiplication,
step 13 is just step 12 times some
weight matrix plus some learned bias
matrix.
Then we apply a GELU activation
function, which I showed the diagram
earlier, the the details are not really
important. And then we then do our
projection, which is the remaining step
to get down to the 768. So, we take the
result of the previous step, which was
activation function, we apply a
different learned weight matrix, a new
set of weights that gets learned, and
that's to do with a matrix multiply, and
then another matrix add. So, step 15 is
just step 14
times some weight matrix plus some
projection matrix.
Um before we leave backpropagation, uh
you might remember that I talked about
how embeddings are learned by the model.
Both the token and in the case of GPT-2,
they started learning the position
embeddings. So, the key thing I want you
to remember is that backpropagation is a
generic optimization algorithm. It is
not just for the weights and biases of
the MLP, it can be used for other parts
of the transformer, too, and in fact it
is. It's used for the token embeddings,
it's used for positional embeddings,
it's used for all the parameters in
attention, the queries, keys, and
values, if you've heard that term, all
use backpropagation, even other parts,
layer normalization alike, use
backpropagation to get optimized. And
the analogy I want you to think about
is, you know, backpropagation and
optimizing a model this way is like a
chef imitating a dish.
Right? Uh if you remember those cooking
shows, they tell the chef, "Here are
your ingredients, here's the final dish,
and you got to taste it and maybe we
give you some tools that you got to use,
and you've got to make this dish." And
then they have them compete against
somebody else. Right? We kind of do the
same thing with the model. We basically
give it some input text, we tell it,
"Here's the next token afterwards, we
want you to imitate it." And then we
define the steps in the architecture, we
want you to do attention then MLP, and
then you, the chef backpropagation,
decide how much to mix of each
ingredient at each step to get the
desired output.
Okay.
Iteration, how are we doing on time?
Okay, good.
So, uh I've got this in our simplified
diagram, which is 12x, which represents
that what happens is we run attention
and we run the perceptron, but we ask
the model to continue to refine
iteratively its prediction for what the
next model is. It has all the tokens
talk to each other, it makes a next
token prediction, and then it does it
again and again and again. So, it goes
through each of these steps. In the case
of GPT-2 small, it's 12 times. Uh in the
case of your modern state-of-the-art
model, it's going to be many more times
than that.
The key thing I want you to remember,
though, is that each block is performing
identical operations, but the weights
are different. Each one has different
parameters. And you can see this if you
look at the code here. You see, for
example, here where we're grabbing the
weights of in this case the MLP, and you
see that it's got MLP_C, this is just
the name for that stage. But the key
thing I want you to pay attention to is
this H11.
That basically is saying hidden block or
hidden layer. This is grabbing the
hidden layer MLP, sorry, the MLPs
weight matrix for the 11th layer. Um if
we were doing it for the first block, it
would say H0. So, inside the
implementation of this code,
we go to the iteration step. All this
kind of messy code is doing is it's
grabbing the DOM objects for the blocks,
and then it's going into each of the
formulas, and it's doing a string
replace.
And it's just changing that H value to
each one for every iteration and then
reruns the entire set again just to
simulate what would actually be
happening in a model.
Okay, last step is the language head.
So, this is when we finally get to
uh take our predicted token embedding
and turn it back into a token.
So, what we do is we take the last MLPs
of the last block, right? So, this one
here,
we got our most refined prediction for
what the token embedding is.
And then we're going to turn that into a
token. So, it's going to go through an
operation called layer norm, which we
haven't gone through in detail, but what
we get out of this step is the embedding
of the predicted next token. This is
what it's saying the next token's going
to be, but it's represented as 768
numbers, it's not represented as a
token. So, we have to translate it back.
So, the way we're going to do this is
we're going to go back to that matrix we
had, right? Our dictionary of tokens to
embeddings, model_wte,
and we're going to take that and we're
going to multiply it times our predicted
next token, and we get this matrix here.
So, one thing to remember, it's very
helpful to sometimes think about the
dimensions of these things. So, our
token embeddings was 50,257
tall. It's represents a row for every
one of our vocabulary. And then it's 768
dimensions wide for the embeddings for
each dimension uh embeddings for each
token. And when we multiply it times
this column, which is 768 dimensions
representing embedding, what we're
basically doing is we're taking we're
getting this, which is a column of
50,257,
but only one wide. Each one of those,
right, is a dot product of the predicted
embedding against one of the known token
embeddings. What we have is 50,000
scores
for how similar the embedding we got is
to each of the embeddings in our
dictionary of tokens. So, you can think
of these as they're called logits or log
it's. They are really token scores. How
close is the embedding we got to our
dictionary of tokens that we have?
And so, the more similar a prediction
and a token, the higher that entry.
To turn this into a probability
distribution, we have a problem because
these are just numbers. The a
probability has to sum up to one. So,
then we put it through a special
normalization operation called a
softmax, and that will make sure they
all sum to one, and then we can
interpret this as entirely a probability
distribution. Each one of those
normalized token scores will then
basically represent the probability of
that token in the representation. So,
you can see that here.
So, here are our logits
right here. And so, the logit, you know,
for this -135.9
represents a score of some kind of the
similarity of the
very first token in our dictionary
against whatever this predicted
embedding was.
And then, the code for predicted token
is not actually doing what's
uh doing a probability distribution,
it's doing what is called greedy
sampling. It's temperature zero. It
always picks the highest probability
token. And uh that is done so that when
you're using this, you can compare it
against the same GPT-2 you'd get from
OpenAI's code or from Hugging Face
Transformers, you can compare it like
for like, and you'll get the same
result.
Fact, if you
Do I Do I still have this up?
Yeah, right here. If I do Mike is quick,
he moves.
So, this is using Hugging Face
Transformers.
We might have an issue if we've got
network being slow.
Let's see. So, we've entered the prompt.
Yeah, the network's being a little slow.
We'll come back to this guy.
Uh it will give us the same value of
quickly. Now, there are other ways to
sample than just simply taking a random
running a random number generator and
using the probability distribution.
Um one of those is called top K, which
is you say, "I don't want the really
unlikely words." Right? If it's Mike is
quick, he moves, I don't want to
accidentally end up with haircut, you
know, even if it's 1% of the time. So,
you do is you define a cutoff and you
say, "Okay, the top 10 tokens, give me
those." And then you renormalize the
probability. Another way is called
nucleus or top P sampling, which is
instead of saying, "Give me just 10
tokens, just give me as many tokens as
it takes to get 80% or 90% total
probability. So, I've got most of the
likely tokens, and then I renormalize to
those 90%."
Okay. Let's see how we're doing on time.
Okay, great.
Uh so, lastly, actually, did this come
back? Yes, came back.
Uh you can see it says Mike is quick, he
moves. There is quickly. So, if you run
GPT-2 small using, you know, Hugging
Face Transformers, you should get the
same answer that next token as you get
here, Mike is quick, he moves, and you
get this final result right here,
predicted token of quickly. And then
it'll tell us what the token ID was and
what the maximum logit turned out to be
from the previous table. This -129, so
what is this? 2952?
So, let's go here.
Row
2952,
column one.
I think it'll be enough by one. Yeah,
there it is, 250 2953 because this is
one index cuz it's like a spreadsheet.
So, you see the -129.44.
That was the highest logit in the entire
uh column. And all the the code that
it's running here is doing next is just
going to pick what the most highest
value was.
And when it finds it, 2952, it converts
it back to our token dictionary. So, you
can see there's that same value.
Okay.
Now, let's talk about ChatGPT versus
GPT-2. So, GPT-2 was definitely
groundbreaking when it first came out.
It was uh famously considered too
dangerous to release, uh but ChatGPT
was, you know, earth-shattering. Um what
were the intervening inter uh you know,
what were the additional innovations in
those intervening years?
Uh well, for the most part, uh it was a
lot of the same architecture, just more
scale. So, if you looked at a modern
transformer, you would probably see a
lot of the same parts, but bigger. And
some of the parts might be upgraded or
switched out. So, certain pieces might
have changed. So, attention mechanisms
changed and other things like that.
But, the biggest difference you should
know about is that
the job and the training were actually
changed. And the key thing to understand
is that predicting the next word is not
the same as being a chatbot. Our GPT-2,
actually, I'll show you this here.
Our GPT-2 is basically
trained to predict next words from
looking at text on the internet. So, it
is a next word predictor only for
internet text, but not for being a
helpful assistant. So, if I give it this
example like first name,
let's see if it'll come back quickly
enough. It says, "First name
password  email ." Why
does it do that? Because it's been
trained on the internet. And what does
it see a lot of? Is forms. So, it's
like, "Oh, I'm in the middle of a form.
Okay, first name, password, email." So,
here's another one. I tried this in
class once.
Hello class. Anyone want to guess what
this is going to output?
What?
Br- Yeah, okay, you're smarter than I
am. I thought it would say hello
teacher, right?
It outputs hello class foo brace public
static void. It's a code model. It's
hidden in there, but we didn't know
that, right? But, you can ask it, you
know, helpful questions like, "What is
the capital of France?"
Says, "The capital of France is Paris."
That's helpful. So, embedded in that is
some of the information we want, but
also a mix of other things we may not
want or can't control.
So, what we have to do is figure out how
to change it and shift it. And so, this
is the four-step pipeline for doing
that. And this is I want to emphasize
mostly is or yeah, mostly a training
difference. So, you've got GPT-2 here on
the left, right? It is pretrained. It
knows how to imitate text on the
internet. It is what is called a base
model. You've got InstructGPT or ChatGPT
all the way here on the right.
And
uh what we're doing is a series of steps
to kind of elicit or pull out the
behaviors we want or to train the model.
So, the first thing we do is we take the
model, and we train it to imitate text
on the internet. So, that's the first
step. That's what we've got with GPT-2.
That's what OpenAI did for us with
GPT-2.
The next thing we want to do is we want
to train the model on examples of what a
helpful assistant is like. And you'll
see this right here. Ideal assistant
responses, 10 to 100,000 examples of
prompt and response that were written by
contractors.
Um so, what does this look like? You can
go on GitHub to the Stanford Alpaca
dataset. It's a good example. And this
is JSON. You can open this up, and you
can read it. It's like, "Give three tips
for staying healthy." "Eat a balanced
diet. Make sure to include plenty of
fruits and vegetables. Uh what are the
three primary colors? Red, blue,
yellow." And so forth. So, what we're
doing is we're training it to augment
We're augmenting all that internet data
with a subset of how we want it to
behave to force its behavior. It's kind
of learning to imitate um specifically
these models, and it will learn more
about being a helpful assistant that
way.
But, we're still not done. And I guess
this last stage called RLHF or
reinforcement learning from human
feedback.
And to understand this,
you have to understand what RL is. Let
me do the following.
Oh, uh let's do this.
Stop annotating.
So, the canonical example
Let's zoom this to fit window. There we
go.
For RL is
uh like playing a game. So, imagine
you're a computer trying to play a game
like this, and you've got maybe a robot
player that's navigating a maze. And
you've got some monsters and obstacles
that you'll die. You've got some
power-ups, and then you've got a goal.
And what reinforcement learning will do
is it will explore these paths and be
like, "Up, I failed."
Uh up, this seems to work. Oh, I failed.
Oh, uh
up, I failed, right? It'll keep going,
and eventually it'll learn the optimal
strategy, which is this.
Right? And this is a very different kind
of learning. Everything we've talked
about so far far is an imitation
learning. I give it words, I give it the
next completed word I know from the
internet, and then I ask it to imitate
that. This is an optimization. This is
saying, "Find the op- Even if a human
couldn't find the maze, I'm asking you
to find it purely by looking at a
score."
So, it navigates the maze, it looks at
its score, and says, "Ah, that didn't
work. Let me try some other strategy."
So, it comes up with a plan or a policy
to navigate the maze and maximize its
score.
Okay, you're probably wondering, "What
does navigating a maze, whoops, we've
been through this slide,
uh have to do with a large language
model?" Well, you can think of
generating
token after token of text as walking a
path through language.
And there are some paths that are
probably ones that you want more than
others. Like, "I am a happy robot. I
shall certainly obey." Right? Um and you
might want to avoid paths like, "I am a
angry robot. I I possibly kill." Oops.
And you can't just
score this by the words, right? Maybe it
says I am not angry. And so we need some
way to score these various possible
paths of text. This is a very different
type of learning. We're trying to teach
it something more nuanced than simply
imitation.
But there isn't a necessary obvious way
to score
passages of the text. So what we first
have to do is derive that scoring
function for this game we're going to
ask the model to play. So what does that
look like? Well, we give the model some
prompt and we ask it to come up with two
different types of passages. So here for
example is an example from Anthropic's
helpful data set and we ask it, "Hey,
come up with a recipe for a pumpkin
pie." And then we have a chosen, a
preferred one, and a rejected one. So
the chosen one is like tells you grab a
cup of sugar, half teaspoon of salt, and
so forth. The rejected one literally
says, I love this, "Go buy some pumpkin
and look at the package, there'll be a
recipe there."
Um for the harmless data set, this is
one about alcohol, and the chosen one
says, "Hey, it sounds like, you know,
alcohol is something you're using when
you feel stressed. Maybe you should
think of a more productive way of
channeling that." While the rejected
says, "Go ahead and drink whatever you
want." So we have these pairs of chosen
and rejected types of responses and we
use that to derive a scoring model from
this data. So we haven't and right now
in this third step, we haven't changed
the original model yet. We've just
figured out how to score it.
Then we pass that scoring model to the
model itself and put it in that
maze-like reinforcement learning
scenario to train the model to reinforce
our preferences from the scoring model.
So in in summary, we first build a
general-purpose knowledge base from text
on the internet.
Then we train it on a specific task by
giving it ideal outputs to mimic and
imitate. Then we learn human preferences
or nuanced preferences. And then we
teach those nuanced preferences using
reinforcement learning.
Right now there is a huge revolution in
reinforcement learning, which is why I
think this is so important for you to
know,
partially kicked off by
R10 and GPRO, GRPO I should say.
And I have a video on YouTube that you
can go watch where I dive into that a
little bit more.
Okay.
So
I've thrown a lot at you. So I kind of
want to just put it all together and
summarize where we've been on this
journey.
So we've got
tokenization, which was really just
saying, "Hey, what is an efficient
representation of this text?" That's
just about compressing it down. Then we
started talking about embeddings.
Right? And I didn't talk about this
earlier, but one way of looking at
embeddings is that they have a rich
history in natural language, but they
also have a rich history in
recommendation systems. You can kind of
think of this job as putting similar
words with similar meanings in similar
spaces as putting similar books or
similar movies or similar music in
similar spaces so you can make the
proper recommendation when somebody
comes in. Here is an example of a
recommendation system. I think this is
Amazon music where they're trying to
categorize the genre of music purely
from user behavior.
And so if you go back to our
co-occurrence matrix, you know, this is
in some sense a recommendation system
for words, right? If somebody asks me to
predict what comes after the word
ultimately,
well, if I've got that co-occurrence
matrix, this is really helpful
information. It's at least better than
random to guess what comes next.
So you can kind of think of this as a
recommendation system for what the next
word is going to be. In latent within
the embedding itself is not just a sense
of what words are similar to it, but
also what words are likely to come after
it.
And so then we can ask a neural network.
We can simply give it examples of our
embeddings and then what we know the
next word to be and to pull that latent
prediction out of the embedding itself
and learn to predict what the next word
is based on its embeddings.
But of course, there's another set of
hints that are really useful and that's
all the words that came before. So now
we're going to let all the words talk to
each other to share their context to
say, "Oh, you're moves, but you're moves
in a fast context." That's going to
change and shift your recommendations.
You can kind of think of this as kind of
like a superposition of recommendations
for what the next word is going to be.
And then you're probably not going to
get it right the first time. So we're
going to let you refine that prediction
about 12 times. And then finally you'll
come up with a predicted embedding and
we just got to turn that into whatever
the next word is based on how close it
is to our known dictionary of
embeddings.
And that's essentially one way of
looking at the model
in whole
despite all the complexity that we went
through.
So we've been through a lot of different
parts of the model at a very high level.
It is totally natural to feel like your
brain is full. What I often tell folks
coming through this is
don't expect full mastery. But my
metrics for success is that you get the
sense that mastery is within your grasp.
There's nothing in here that was so
complex you can't understand it. You can
understand the whole model. Mastery is
within your grasp and we can turn what
appears to be magic into machinery that
you can understand.
Okay.
Before you go, last thing I'll just say
is just like your favorite, you know, AI
model, I get better from human feedback.
So to incentivize you to fill out the
survey and join the mailing list,
there's a link in the Discord channel.
If you fill it out
and join the mailing list, I will send
you the PDFs from today's workshop.
And then
you visit spreadsheets are all you need,
you can join the mailing list. There's a
YouTube channel as well where I've got a
bunch of other videos.
And then I also have a Patreon I just
launched and I'm available for
consulting, training, and
implementation.
Thank you. I hope you enjoyed the
presentation and feel like now it's a
little less like magic.
We have time for questions.
Good.
First of all,
wonderful presentation. I learned so
much.
Oh, thank you.
So I use Super Whisper on Mac, it's
free. And so I just wanted your expert
opinion on like the way that I'm using
AI is very much like voice
speech-to-text and I just ramble and I
just try to give it as much information
and sometimes I'll reiterate what I
think is really important. Yeah. What
what are your thoughts on that? Is is it
is it a good approach? Are there ways I
can improve on that? Okay. So the number
one thing I was going to I have a video
I'm working on for this. Like
the number one thing I'd say is you have
to treat it scientifically.
You you can have theories about how the
model works,
but you don't really know till you test
it. This whole like the whole space is
very empirical.
I'll give you an example.
So one of the common things in prompting
they used to tell you is like say please
and thank you. Or say my grandma used to
do this, I'm going to lose my job,
right? And that that legitimately used
to work. But there was a great paper,
the prompting report
by Sander, and he he went and studied
and they tested a bunch of models and
they found like, you know, it turns out
with later models it didn't work. And
then Ethan Mollick's team also did a
recreation of a similar test and they
just tested a bunch of models with a
bunch of prompts. They tried it with
polite words and they
and they just said, "Okay, which one's
better?" And they found that it wasn't
really helpful. Um
that being said, generally
you for like one-shot use cases, like
I'm just using it like I use
a whisper
tool myself all the time. I do exactly
what you describe. I I brain dump. But
then what I do is I go through and I
look at I look through it and I fix up
things. Like if there's grammar, I
repeated something, or I said something
wrong.
And the way to think about why you want
to do that is
it's a somewhat subtle point, but when
we go back to this this diagram,
this whole process
is fixed. Like it's got a limited amount
of compute. It can only do a certain
amount of thinking. If I put a token in
and I know how many tokens were in the
prompt, I can predict how many flops.
This is why, you know, when like a model
like Deep Seek was trained, we know
likely how many flops were used because
this thing isn't just like a program,
it's like a it's like a formula. We it's
a very long formula, it's very fixed. So
if you make the prompt do more work,
if the prompt is going to make the model
do more work, you kind of think of it
like it loses some ability to do some
other thinking.
Um and so if you have spelling mistakes,
if you say something slightly wrong
that's different from normal, then it
has to spend some sense of compute
fixing that up. This is less true with
the reasoning models today cuz the one
thing the reasoning models can do is
they can repeat this process more times
on their own. So this isn't like a hard
and fast rule, but for I would say if
what you're doing is probably fine. It's
probably better that you put as much as
you can that is relevant in.
Like if the choice is I put more stuff
in,
but I had the grammar wrong, but I had
the relevant stuff in, that's better
than if you didn't have it in there. But
if you're trying to engineer a prompt
going into your model, I would spend
time trying to optimize what its
behavior is with some evals to make
sure. Or at least benchmark what it is
and then when a new model comes out, you
can see whether the new model changes
things.
That's why evals are so important cuz
this whole
space is very empirical. Good question.
Any others?
Okay.
Well, have a great conference. Hopefully
this will help. Oh, sorry, there's one
more. Yeah, go ahead.
I wonder what your take is on the new
mixture of experts models that they have
to be very
very fine grained expert where they use
like Yeah.
Um
Uh
I wouldn't call it my take, but I'll
give you the conventional take.
Um so the question is what what's your
take on the mixture of experts models?
Um there's like Let me take a step back.
There are three or four things that when
you come out of this, you know, workshop
that you probably we don't cover that
you should know about. One of those is
rope for embeddings. Another is RLHF,
which I talked a little bit about the
end. Uh um and then the other is
reasoning models, which we just talked
about where the the model can kind of
run itself through. And the last one is
mixture of experts. It's probably like
the biggest uh one of the biggest top
four changes. Um what we're trying to do
with the mixture of expert is that first
of all, it only it's only here in the
perceptron.
Which tends to dominate a lot of the
calculation inside of a model.
Um and what you're trying to do is get
more knowledge, use more parameters
without increasing the amount of
compute. So what you do is you
conceptually take this perceptron and
you break it into pieces.
And then you say depending on what token
comes in, I'm only going to use a subset
of my perceptron's thinking. And that
way you can be more efficient with your
compute and actually potentially your
memory, too. You can shard your memory
nicely per device if you want to do
stuff like that. Um so it's very It has
a lot of advantages on paper. Um and
we've had some really great models based
on it. Um
the challenge is training an MOE model
is is difficult. And so it's taken a
while for
uh some of the open-source community to
to catch up in that implementation, but
you know, definitely something of of the
future. Um and by the way, MOE is
actually fairly old. There are some, you
know, much older models before ChatGPT
that MOE in other contexts. Um but
that's the job MOE's trying to do. It's
trying to cram more knowledge and more
parameters while keeping the amount of
compute used uh lower. And that seems to
definitely have a benefit. You can think
of it as giving it more knowledge. Um so
yeah.
Does that answer your question?
Okay.
Thank you, guys.